[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
numéro spécial d'europe et d'eau
consacré aux élections européennes tout
au long du mois de mai nous vous
proposons à des débats entre les
candidats ou leurs soutiens sur les
thèmes qui font la campagne et cette
semaine nous nous intéressons à
l'immigration enjeu important pour
l'avenir de l'union européenne la crise
migratoire de 2015 et la gestion de
l'immigration elle divise les pays de
l'union européenne qui n'arrivent pas à
trouver un accord
comment gérer les flux migratoires
faut-il remettre à plat les accords de
schengen comment contrôler les
frontières
nous en débattrons dans quelques
instants avec nos quatre invités mais
avant cela nous allons faire un tour
d'horizon de la campagne en france les
candidats multiplient les déplacements
et les meetings
aurélie d'afas a sélectionné pour vous
les temps forts de cette semaine de
campagne
edouard philippe s'engage dans la
campagne le premier ministre apporte son
soutien à la candidate de la majorité
présidentielle
il est apparu à ses côtés lors d'un
meeting à quand un engagement
gouvernemental pour essayer de redonner
du souffle à la campagne
loiseau sa liste reste pour l'instant au
coude à coude avec le rassemblement
national dans les sondages
trente-trois listes ont été déposées
pour les élections européennes en france
un nombre record les partis politiques
traditionnels représentent environ la
moitié des listes les électeurs auront
aussi le choix entre trois formations
issues du mouvement des gilet jaune
en tout ce sont plus de 2600 candidats
qui se présenteront au scrutin du 26 mai
[Musique]
entouré de ses colistiers raphaël
glucksmann a présenté sa liste et son
projet l'essayiste tête de liste pour le
ps et places publiques proposent un
programme qui se veut à la rencontre du
social et de l'écologie alors que la
liste est à la traîne dans les sondages
raphaël glucksmann a exhorté les
électeurs à choisir en fonction de leurs
convictions
se réjouissant que la campagne commence
enfin à trois semaines de l'échéance
marine le pen fait campagne en belgique
la dirigeante du rassemblement national
est allé à la rencontre de ses alliés
belge du vlaams belang a plant les
bruxellois a voté pour la formation
flamande
à cette occasion elle a rappelé son
ambition de constituer ce qu'elle
appelle un super groupe au sein du futur
parlement avec des partis nationalistes
de toute l'europe
elle a ainsi tendu la main aux hongrois
viktor orban ainsi qu'au parti droit et
justice au pouvoir en pologne les
républicains font campagne sur le thème
de l'immigration
en meeting à marseille françois-xavier
bellamy a dénoncé un déni de réalité
il a souligné l'urgence de maîtriser les
flux et de mettre fin à l'immigration
illégale
affirmant la crise migratoire n'a pas
encore commencé
[Musique]
et avant d'entamer notre débat sur
l'immigration voudrais vous entendre
tous les quatre de manière très brève
sur cette actualité de campagne qu'on
vient de voir fabienne keller on va
commencer avec vous bonjour la liste
renaissance c'est la liste de la
majorité présidentielle 1 qui regroupe
la république en marche le modem et agir
dont vous faites partie
on a vu lundi soir edouard philippe en
meeting à caen avec nathalie l'oiseau
helder filipe est obligé de voler au
secours de va peut-être de lui mais non
il est naturellement avec cette liste
avec nathalie l'oiseau il est de
centre-droit nous nous le savons il
porte la politique du gouvernement avec
engagement et détermination
j'ai le plaisir de faire campagne avec
lui autour d'alain juppé
c'est bien sûr sa place mais il n'allait
pas le faire depuis longtemps voilà il
le fait dans cette dernière ligne droite
où la campagne devient un sujet majeur
en france et je m'en réjouis qu'on parle
d'europe enfin c'est pas un sujet très
très facile et donc il est vraiment
important de dire des choses et des
choses vraies jean marc germain bon
genre 0 lundi da sur la liste parti
socialiste place publique on a vu
raphaël luxe man présenté sa liste
raphaël glucksmann et bien il va être la
surprise de cette élection alors pour le
moment la surprise n est pas très bonne
pour vous vous flirter avec la barre des
5% est ce qu'il ya un risque de
disparition des socialistes français au
parlement européen
écoutez la compagne commencé il ya
toujours une surprise dans l'est dans
les campagnes électorales en 2009 je me
souviens c'était europe ecologie les
verts au jour on se parle il était à 7%
dans les sondages et ils ont fini à 16%
donc notre espoir c'est que place
publique avec le parti socialiste avec
nouvelle donne avec les radicaux de
gauche c'est déjà une vraie réussite
qu'on soit ensemble pour s'attaquer aux
problèmes d'écologie et de social en
même temps parce que c'est ça l'idée de
cette liste dans une liste profondément
européenne parce qu'on pense que les
solutions sont européennes et avec ce
qu'on appelle de nos combattants de la
social écologie qui sont des belles
personnalités nicolas v bonjour candidat
pour le rassemblement national on a vu
marine le pen dimanche on
gic soutenir vos alliés du vlaams belang
des alliés qui prône l'indépendance de
la france de la flandre la fin de la
belgique ça ne vous posera pas de
problème c'est une des particularités de
la vie politique belge le vlaams belang
d'air n'est pas le seul parti politique
à défendre l'idée d'une séparation entre
la flandre et la wallonie et c'est un
cas particulier propre à la belgique 1
qui dont l'unité est assez récente il ya
quelques seulement deux siècles pour
être tout à fait précis nous nous avons
des alliés en flandre bien sûr nous
avons des alliés partout en europe nous
allons constituer une grande coalition
avec une quinzaine de nationalités c'est
vrai qu'il ya encore une inconnue sur
est ce que les polonais du parti de la
justice sera avec nous ou est-ce que les
hongrois du fides séparé du ppe ou le
saura dans les prochains mois peut-être
même les prochaines années et ça nous
empêchera pas de toute façon de
constituer cette force qui montre que
l'europe des nations c'est pas qu'un
slogan c'est en train de devenir une
vraie élite est et le débat de ces
élections européennes c'est pas
contrairement à ce que certains disent
bêtement ceux qui sont pour et ceux qui
sont contre l'europe
la question c'est qu'est l'europe et on
va finir cette heure d'horizon avec vos
gens disaient bonjour vous êtes
président l'est républicain de la
commission des affaires européennes ici
au sénat vous soutenez la liste de
françois xavier bel ami françois-xavier
dynamique qui a fait une remontée dans
les sondages depuis le début de la
campagne mais qui reste loin de votre
score à la présidentielle est ce que
vous avez perdu une grande partie de
votre base électorale
la situation je dirais politique n'est
favorable à personne mais il est vrai
que françois-xavier bellamy effectué une
très belle remontée
c'est un philosophe je dirais à la belle
parole qui élève le débat
il est très séduisant je pense qu'il va
surprendre
c'est noté et merci à tous les quatre
pour ce tour d'horizon de l'actualité
place maintenant aux grands débats de
cette émission consacrée à l'immigration
[Musique]
et avant de vous laisser débattre sur
les propositions que vous défendez sur
ce thème en point sur les chiffres clés
avec laura sauvage
on
en 2010 8 580 mille huit cents personnes
ont déposé pour la première fois une
demande d'asile dans l'union européenne
un net recul par rapport à 2015 où elle
avait atteint un pic avec plus d'un
million de demandes
près de trois demandes d'asile sur dix
sont enregistrés en allemagne la france
arrive en deuxième position suivi de la
grèce et de l'espagne
les syriens les afghans et les irakiens
sont les nationalités les plus concernés
pour déposer une demande d'asile dans
l'un des 28 états membres
le règlement de dublin s'applique ce
dispositif oblige le demandeur a déposé
son dossier dans le premier pays de
l'union où il a mis les pieds mais en
63 % des demandes d'asile ont été
déboutés jugé inégalitaire par les
principaux pays d'entrée la grèce et
l'italie
le règlement de dublin est au coeur de
la controverse depuis la crise
migratoire
les 28 ne parviennent pas à s'entendre
non plus sur la refonte des accords de
schengen 26 pays sont membres de cet
espace qui prévoit la libre circulation
et le contrôle des frontières
face à l'afflux de migrants lieux a mis
en place en 2004 l'agencé européenne de
contrôle aux frontières frontex regroupe
aujourd'hui 1500 agents chargés de
protéger les côtes de l'europe
son budget a doublé et devrait atteindre
322 millions d'euros en 2020
[Musique]
on
alors on entend beaucoup parler
d'immigration mais quand on voit les
chiffres
est ce que l'union européenne fait
vraiment face à une crise migratoire
migratoires ou est-ce que ce sujet est
un petit peu monté en épingle nicolas
bay je crois qu'on fait face à une crise
migratoire kiné qui ne date pas de 2015
qui est antérieur et qui va se
poursuivre dans les prochaines années
on sait que les les motivations des
migrants qui arrivent et à l'europe sont
diverses
les motivations c'est parfois la guerre
mais ont finalement en progression assez
limité c'est souvent des situations
économiques qu'ils fuient c'est parfois
aussi des situations liées aux
modifications climatiques et par
conséquent la réponse doit être complète
la réponse ça doit pas être de les faire
venir alors qu'il ya plus d'el dorado ni
français ni européen
ça doit être à la fois la fermeté mais
évidemment une aussi une politique
ambitieuse de développement notamment
des infrastructures dans les pays
africains parce que c'est principalement
d'afrique que vient cette immigration le
problème c'est qu'on a une immigration
légale et clandestine qui se cumulent et
l'immigration clandestine qui arrive en
europe et bien elle aboutit en pratique
au maintient durablement sur le sol
européen des personnes y compris celles
qui sont les buttes et du droit d'asile
puisque un rapport récent de la cour des
comptes montrait que 94 % de ceux qui
sont déboutés du droit d'asile
c'est à peu près les deux tiers de ceux
qui font des demandes d'asile en france
on a 120 mille par an en france qui font
des demandes d'asile et bien 94% d'entre
eux ne sont jamais expulsé dix ans non
vous ne pouvez pas venir si vous venez
illégalement vous serez expulsé c'est le
meilleur moyen d'éviter de à beaucoup de
gens de tenter la traversée de la
méditerranée d'engraisser les mafias les
passeurs parfois aussi de mort hier en
méditerranée on l'a vu avec matteo
salvini calais s'est abaissé
drastiquement le nombre d'arrivées sur
les côtes italiennes
il a en même temps baisser le nombre de
morts en méditerranée on va les crs
chargent en marge à main je pense que
quand on réfléchit à la question de
l'immigration mais là on est en train de
parler de la question du droit d'asile
des réfugiés il faut d'abord penser aux
femmes et aux hommes qui fuient leur
pays et aux raisons pour lesquelles ils
fuient ces pays donc il faut toujours de
placer à la place de ces femmes et de
ces hommes et se dire si j'étais avec ma
famille avec mes enfants avec le risque
qu'ils soient assassinés ou violenter
est ce que je ferais la même chose
qu'eux et à ce moment là quand il arrive
à nos portes en europe on raisonne tout
à fait différemment
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans nos
propositions on dit qu'il faut arrêter
de faire de cette question là un enjeu
politique
c'est une obligation internationale et
donc il faut qu'elles soient traitées
non plus au niveau des états qui se
renvoient les réfugiés entre eux c'est à
qui en prendra le moins que le voisin
mais au niveau repères et donc on
propose un office de l'asile européen
qui serait indépendant qui dit oui ou
non est ce que vous venez d'un pays est
ce que vous êtes en danger et on propose
une règle d'automaticité c'est à dire
vous avez parlé du règlement dublin
c'est plus est les pays limitrophes
c'est en fonction de votre population
est votre capacité d'accueil donc de la
situation du marché du travail
vous prenez votre part de cette
obligation est de ce devoir d'humanité
mais quand même fabienne keller le poids
de l'immigration est inégalement
répartie entre les différents pays
européens est ce que la france ont fait
assez ou est ce que c'est des charges
trop sur son voisin alors nous avons
fait le choix en europe de définir cette
zone les 26 états membres avec une
frontière commune et une gestion commune
de la migration
il faut donc se donner les moyens et
l'europe est en quelque sorte à un mi
chemin
nous proposons un renforcement au delà
de ce qui a été déjà fait 1 en trois ans
une plus que doubler le budget de
frontex en passant à 10 mille gardes
côtes et gardes-frontières que font-ils
il épaule les polices nationales au
moment où il ya une pression migratoire
par exemple sont très présents avec des
bateaux et des avions d'ailleurs à
lesbos cette île grecque qui est très
proche des côtes turques et où beaucoup
de mafieux de passeurs essaye de
transporter des personnes non
renforcement des moyens collectifs pour
qu'ils puissent intervenir sur la zone
de pression migratoire et deuxième étape
c'est l'harmonisation des règles d'asile
en effet aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui crée
le malheur pour les ce qu'on appelle les
dubly nez c'est un mot terrible
ce sont des personnes qui entrent dans
un pays comme vous l'expliqué dans un
dans votre reportage soit obligé de
déposer leur demande d'asile dans ce
pays là mais qui savent que le les
conditions seront plus favorables dans
un autre état membre et donc qu'ils
essayent de redéposer une demande c'est
c'est pas l'europe sera donc nous
proposons une harmonisation de ces
règles d'asile et l'application de
mesures dès lors qu' il ne fuit pas un
conflit ne remplissent pas les
conditions qui leur permettent d'être
réfugié alors avec humanité mais fermeté
les reconduire vers leur pays d'origine
c'est tout le travail que fait
aujourd'hui fabrice les gérer le patron
de contexte enfin un grand plan pour
l'afrique est indispensable rappaz des
relations historiques avec l'afrique
c'est une zone à la démographie très
très positive
c'est aussi une zone de talent et de
dynamisme
donc il est important que l'europe
construisent une relation responsables
et équilibrés en soute et les industries
les activités qui progressivement
peuvent se développer dans les pays du
sud et assurer une autre perspective aux
habitants qui sinon deviennent migrants
économies sur ce point là vous êtes
d'accord un nicolas v jean bizet 1 sur
cette question de l'afrique jean bizet
on va peut-être vous entendre vous sur
cette question on faisait pas encore
entendu écoutez moi je vous renvoie au
discours sur l'état de l'union du
président jeune choeur qui a eu le
courage politique de l'annoncé
ce que nous avons vécu en deux en 2015
avec un pic migratoire auxquels l'europe
n'était pas préparé un million huit cent
mille je dirais migrants ont déferlé je
dirais sur nos pays alors quelles que
soient les qualités de frontex sous
l'autorité d'un français n'ont pas
beaucoup donc nommons le monsieur les
gérer on n'était pas préparé à cela donc
demain
dix mille gardes frontières qui devront
épauler les états qui seraient en
difficulté pour gérer tout cela très
bien par contre vous en pour vous ce
sera déjà ce sera déjà pas mal avec un
budget qui multiplié par deux mais il
faut oublier il faut pas oublier pardon
les sommets de la valette
il y en a eu quelques autres ensuite
notamment
abidjan avec un partenariat avec les
pays entre guillemets excusez moi
l'expression pourvoyeur de ces migrants
sur lequel il faut avoir
je dirais de un co investissement et un
grand plan marshall sur l'afrique parce
que ce que nous avons vécu en 2015 à
horizon 2040 2050
ce sera 2 milliards 2 milliards
d'africains qu'en fait-on si au travers
d'une réflexion
on ne peut pas les laisser je dirais
travailler dans leur propre pays pour
qu'ils assument
je dirais le leur cursus humain et
professionnel
ce qui nous amène à la question des
quotas en des clés de répartition par
pays est ce que c'est la bonne solution
ça fait partie de vos propositions vous
rejoindre que jamais non pas des quotas
moi je crois que le critère alors on
mélange un peu de sujets la question des
réfugiés la question l'immigration la
question des réfugiés joly dit pour moi
c'est un droit intangible et il faut
l'appliquer et pour cela l'europe est
essentielle parce que le jour où les
règles sont définies au niveau européen
on ne se posera plus la question de
savoir si vous les accueillir ou pas
comme d'ailleurs c'était le cas avant la
crise de 2015 n'y a pas de débat en
france sur la question des réfugiés du
coup il faut qu'on revienne à 7 à cette
sérénité et d'ailleurs j'ajoute par
rapport à ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
il faut qu'on rétablisse les sauvetages
en mer sur la question de l'immigration
magie un principe simple on doit
accueillir dans la mesure de nos
possibilités et notamment ça se joue
beaucoup au niveau local puisque ces
femmes et ces hommes qui viennent chez
nous habitent dans des territoires
les gens qui ont envie de venir vivre en
france et qui ont envie de partager le
projet politique de la france et donc
nous notre conception profonde c'est
quand on a une personne en face de nous
et d'ailleurs je sais pas quelles sont
nos histoires personnelles mais elles
sont sans doute si on se prolonge un peu
dans ton très diverses on est presque
tous issus de l'immigration où tous par
définition c'est de dire aux gens qu est
ce que vous voulez faire est-ce que vous
adhérez à nos valeurs qui sont la
liberté l'égalité la fraternité donc où
vous voulez aller et pas d'où vous venez
ça c'est le principe de base est ensuite
le deuxième principe c'est ont construit
un accueil très concrètement avec les
collectivités locales et en fonction des
projets
que qui ont les personnes donc en résumé
l'europe elle n'a pas besoin de mur
elle a besoin d'avoir des portes et dans
ses portes là on organise un accueil
nous on appelle ça une immigration juste
et ordonnée des femmes et des hommes qui
ont envie de venir vivre avec nous et
partager notre call avait national et
européen
je crois que le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que l'immigration elle n'est ni
juste ni ordonner elle est massive elle
est anarchique parce que l'immigration
clandestine dont on parle depuis tout à
l'heure elle se cumule avec une
immigration légale en france on a deux
cent cinquante cinq mille personnes qui
entrent au titre de l'immigration légale
120000 qui entrent au titre du demande
d'asile cinquante mille m'isoler des
dizaines de milles destin aussi bien en
outre mer qu'en métropole tout ça on
arrive à près de 450 ou 500 mille par an
c'est évidemment considérable on peut
pas supporter les chiffres officiels et
puis à tout ce qui sort et vous savez
très bien que ça va l'aider quatre mois
maintenant la question c'est de savoir
comment on traite ce problème moi je
veux bien le discours toujours le même
on les accueille en effet venir
on la porte ce coup à l'êta mais encore
une fois on alimente un système où
l'immigration sera toujours plus
important tous les flux seront toujours
plus importants moi je suis d'abord sur
le développement de l'afrique il faut
développer les infrastructures
télécommunications électricité routes
pour développer économiquement et dans
la durée la fiq est pas laisser les
chinois aujourd'hui prendre les
positions que les européens ont perdu
sur le continent africain
tout à fait d'accord mais on doit faire
preuve de fermeté en matière migratoire
frontex
il faut quand même être air à la fois
sur les effectifs et sur les missions de
frontex parce que madame keller vous
nous dites il faut porter à 10 milles
mais c'est déjà fait on a ouvert quand
vous serez députés européens que on le
sait a déjà été décidé de porter à 10
milles les effectifs de france donc
c'est pas du tout une principe
merci voilà le problème c'est la mission
allemand fait pression franchement c'est
dur je suis je suis très présent donc
vous mentez madame keller voilà allez
vérifier les statistiques des dragons
sais pas si on ne comptait pas de
n'importe quoi bon maintenant sur
frontex
ses gants sur frontex dans votre rôle
donc je corrige mozart l effrontée la
visiter le siège de frontex à varsovie
le honda on a reconnu sur place on a
expliqué comment ils procédaient en
élite et bien souvent ils récupèrent les
bateaux de migrants au large des côtes
libyennes et il est
il sécurise leur arrivée sur les côtes
européennes donc en fait il facilite le
travail des mafias et des passeurs donc
évidemment faut sortir de cette logique
là il faut les faire revenir vers le
appliquer le droit de la mer c'est à
dire quand il quitte les côtés où
siègent les ramener à visiter vous avez
vu les nôtres i télé dans vous allez
vous les femmes se font violer vous
allez faire mais vous alimentez ceci
j'alimente pas du tout je vous ai dit
que je ne les ai je tends la main des
gens qui sont méditerranée et le
problème c'est que vous confondez je ne
vous confondez la charité 1,10 et
colarena chrétiens qui en difficulté
tous on va lui porter secours il n'y a
pas de problème je vois la stabilité
posturale su gérer dans un discours on
va laisser faire et kessler me répondit
on va faire venir comme ça
des centaines de milliers ou millions en
salaires en europe c'est totalement
irresponsable représenter le
rassemblement national comme d'habitude
vous utilisez l'anathème d'une part et
les faux chiffres d'autre part donner
leur sang des chiffres de l'immigration
ils ont été re a rappelé dans le
reportage
ils sont officiels vous manipulez en
fait la peur j'ai d'ailleurs à le faire
monsieur bellamy en agitant cette peur
migratoires on voit bien que nos
concitoyens ont besoin d'être rassurés
oui nous avons défini dans leur vérité
en leur disant l'iso la vérité chers
collègues
oui nous avons défini un espace commun
il faut nous doter des outils qui
permettent de le faire respecter
c'est le sens d'un renforcement financer
de frontex qui intervient monsieur b
vous pouvez analyser tout le rapport
annuel qui malheureusement est
aujourd'hui uniquement en anglais de
l'année précédente de frontex et vous
verrez l'ensemble des opérations qu'ils
ont conduit qui vient toujours en
renforcement des politiques nationales
avec beaucoup
d'efficacité ce que vous avez dit à leur
égard est tout à fait intolérable
c'est une saison qui défend les règles
de cela je dire pour que ça il ne suffit
pas que vous êtes très intéressé relatif
très péremptoire que vous dites est
juste faux il ne suffit pas pour de
d'essayer de me couvrir par votre voix
pour transformer la réalité
frontex est un engagement nous y avons
pas mal travaillé avec monsieur bizet en
commission des affaires européennes j'ai
eu l'occasion de le faire plus
personnellement c'est une structure
qu'il faut effectivement renforcée et
qui garantit le droit en europe sur la
question de la prise en charge des
demandeurs d'asile à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne
là aussi je crois je crois que c'est un
débat qu'il faut avoir il ya d'autres
grands pays dans le monde qui ont fait
le choix de quotas il ce qu'il faut des
quotas ou pas en tout cas il faut les
gérer ensemble et il ne faut pas laisser
cette incertitude sur le droit des uns
et des autres c'est les écarts sur le
droit d'asile le rendre l'harmoniser au
niveau européen
créer une agence européenne du droit
d'asile cette indispensable un mot jean
bizet parce qu'après je voudrais qu'on
parle de schengen sur ce qu'a dit
fabienne keller à l'instant
françois-xavier bellamy agitent les
peurs mais pas du tout mais françois
fabié eux
non c'est un raconte la migration
nombreux problèmes mais fabienne keller
je la connais bien un bon c'est pas
parce que fabienne vous venez de changer
de camp qu'il faut également changer de
discours
je n'ai pas changé d très clair il est
le mouvement auquel j'appartenais il est
très clair non à l'extérieur 3-2 ce
sujet et je dirais extrêmement sensible
et que les réponses ne sont pas binaire
mais regardons ce qui se passe en france
les comptes rendus de la cour des
comptes sont je dirais à parable nous
n'avons pas une politique digne de ce
nom en matière de retour dans les pays
d'origine de l'immigration illégale nous
n'avons pas un état de droit regardez ce
qui se passe dans ce pays depuis quand
même quelques semaines bon eh bien tout
pendant qu'on n'aura pas réglé ces
questions là le problème de la migration
sera complètement je dirais occultée par
tous ces choses là
donc voilà on va juste avant de parler
de schengen entendent deux autres
candidats à cette élection c'est
nathalie arthaud pour lutte ouvrière et
françois sinon pour lui père
alors je vous rappelle que l'espace
schengen et l'union européenne ce sont
deux choses 10 juin par exemple elle a
su la l'islande la norvège sont dans
schengen ne sont pas dans l'union
européenne alors que par exemple
l'irlande et le royaume uni sont dans
l'union européenne et ne sont pas dans
schengen donc nous ce que nous voulons
c'est demander aux français ce qu'ils
veulent ou non rester dans schengen mais
vous savez il ya des gens qui disent
aussi tôt ou lalinde et c'est terrible
on va rétablir des frontières mais c'est
le lot commun y compris en france
lorsque vous prenez l'avion ou pour
aller à washington pour aller passer un
week end à marrakech tout pour aller au
royaume uni ou à moscou vous êtes obligé
de présenter vos papiers donc il faut
pas non plus considérer que c'est
quelque chose d'extravagant
nous sommes pour la libre circulation
est un livre installations à l'échelle
effectivement de toute l'europe pour que
les migrants bas puissent effectivement
sauver leur peau mais nous pensons que
c'est un combat c'est le combat que les
travailleurs que les plus pauvres de
cette planète doivent mener
nous nous disons bah voilà ce droit de
circulation de pouvoir franchir des
frontières pour trouver un travail et
pour arles droit de vivre de le droit de
vivre sur cette planète
eh bien ça doit être un droit donné à
tous les travailleurs un droit
élémentaire et nous nous pensons encore
une fois qu' on ne doit pas voir
l'arrivée de femmes et d'hommes qui
veulent se retrousser les manches et
travailler pour gagner leur vie comme un
menace très rapidement je voudrais vous
entendre sur une question celle des
accords de schengen puisque la question
des migrations ça pose aussi la question
des frontières est ce qu'il faut revoir
les accords de schengen et comment dans
leur principe c'est à dire la frontière
commune et la libre circulation à
l'intérieur des frontières
c'est quand même un formidable outil de
développement c'est ce qui a permis de
nous protéger ensemble ensemble me
semble-t-il on est plus forts face au
péril extérieur
l'enjeu qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
c'est de se donner les moyens pour
protéger efficacement cette frontière
commune et c'est tout le sens de ce
renforcement qu'on évoquait de frontex
épauler le pays qui fait un moment donné
l'objet d'une forte pression
jean-marc la main oui et non c'est une
des plus belles idées de la construction
européenne la liberté de pouvoir
circuler
par ailleurs il faut savoir que schengen
a créé ce grand espace de liberté de
circulation mais aussi des mécanismes
qui permettent de faire des contrôles à
la frontière quand il ya des situations
d'urgence particulière
c'est ce qu'avait décidé d'ailleurs
françois hollande en novembre 2015 pour
des questions liées au terrorisme et
j'en disais moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que veut dire monsieur
germain
c'est vrai que schengen ça fait partie
des grands succès de l'europe et c'est
consubstantiel à la création du premier
marché économique mondiale quel marché
unique
l'un n'irait pas sans l'autre alors
souvent l'europe pour ne pas dire
presque toujours donne les bonnes
réponses
mais à son rythme parce que l'europe
c'est le temps des alliances des accords
et des compromis parce que nous ne
sommes pas une structure fédérale alors
je crois qu'il faut respecter aussi
certains états notamment les états
d'europe centrale qui viennent de
recouvrer en quelque sorte depuis
simplement une petite décennie leur
identité et que le concept de quotas les
a particulièrement orthez donc refonder
schengen bon c'est de la sémantique tout
cela mais les bons acquis sont quand
même ceux d'aujourd'hui
nicolas bay quand même animal mac on dit
qu'il faut imposer un principe de
solidarité de responsabilité c'est à
dire si des pays refusent d'accueillir
des migrants sur leur sol et bien ils
doivent être privés de subventions de
l'union européenne qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
je crois qu'il vous fait exactement le
contraire il faut organiser les
coopérations européennes pour contrôler
nos frontières et empêcher cette
immigration massive et anarchique et
faire en sorte que les demandes d'asile
se fasse dans les pays tiers c'est hors
du territoire de l'union européenne
moi quand j'entends mes contradicteurs
je vois que clients ils sont tous pour
maintenir les grandes sommes de l'union
européenne contre la libre circulation
totale des biens et des personnes
c'est-à-dire aussi malheureusement c'est
devenu la libre circulation des
clandestins des délinquants des
criminels les trafics en tout genre et
c'est pas parce qu'il parlait il faut à
la fois contrôlé à des contrôles aux
frontières nationales
c'est pas un gros mot ça permet de voir
et bien sûr oui c'est possible on le
sait et avoir une vraie capacité de
défense de nos frontières extérieures et
j'ajoute qu'il faut pas s'inscrire dans
la logique de l'aide de du laxisme en
matière d'asile parce que le projet de
réforme dublin 4 qui a été préparé par
la commission européenne
avalisé presque tel quel par le
parlement mais qui heureusement bloquée
au conseil par un certain nombre de pays
qui voit le danger est bien ça
consistera à permettre à celui qui
arrive clandestinement en europe de
choisir parmi quatre pays celui où il
s'installe pendant l'instruction de sa
demande d'asile
évidemment il va aller dans le pays qui
est le plus avantageux sur le plan des
aides et avantages sociaux
et puis ensuite évidemment une fois que
son île et des boutiques droit d'asile
eh bien il fera en sorte d'être dans un
pays où ça rendra compliqué impossible
qu'il faut sortir du lot de fabienne
keller qui n'avaient pas voté le
règlement pnr qui permet d'avoir
l'information sur les fichiers des
personnes
oui les échanges de renseignements c'est
un des grands outils de lutte contre le
terrorisme et de prog de protection
contre l'immigration illégale ce qui est
village patrick âge vous avez cliqué sur
règlement vous avez été le premier
contingent d'élus au parlement européen
quand avez vous fait pas ce que vous
pensiez terroristes qui viennent en
avion à la galère et 2 est encore celle
d'illusions magnifique sperme était
comment vous pouvez parler d héroïsme
alors comment parler d'eux ils enfin
tout le monde est d'accord pour lutter
conte avec le pnr les bouffer un
amalgame non mes pensées mali bénin le
pnr c'était fait pour lutter contre les
terroristes vous avez référent de votre
aimable khadr qui permet un passage à
vide et en europe
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir été avec
nous la semaine prochaine des bases sur
la place de l'union européenne dans le
monde très bonne suite de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]